Guten Tag.
So, jetzt geht es einigermaßen. Dank.
Ja, fühlen Sie sich besser.
Haben Sie mir vielleicht eine Brechschale?
Das reicht nicht mehr.
Und ein bisschen Papier.
Was wurde auch von Sie abhin nicht verstanden?
Eine Brechschale.
Brechschale?
Ja, ein Brecher oder ein Papier zum Erbrechen.
Ein Teller, ein Papier, ein Teeter.
Oder eine Tüte.
Ja, ich habe irgendwas zufrieden.
Es würde immer.
Ja, ich verstehe. Ja, bitte schon.
Ich gebe Ihnen.
Danke, danke.
So, jetzt ist besser.
Danke.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Sarah Laude.
Ich bin der
Frau des Nacktnamens.
Sarah Lawrence.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam einbuchstabieren?
Sarah
S-a-r
A-h
Okay, Sarah.
Okay, ich mach es.
Sarah, genau.
Und Lawrence.
Ludwig, Anton, Udo.
Richard, Emil
Ja, war.
Frau Lawrence, wie alt sind Sie und wann genau sind Sie geboren?
Ich bin 22 Jahre alt und bin am 14. August 2000 und zwei geboren.
Wie viel wiegeln Sie und wie groß sind Sie, Frau Lawrence?
Ich bin 1,65 m und habe circa 73 kg.
Frau Lawrence, welche Bescheid haben Sie außer Überkeit?
Herr Doktor, wir sind die, das habe ich schon seit vielen Monaten. Es kommt immer wieder.
Überkeit und Erbrechen?
Überkeit und Erbrechen.
Seit heute Morgen muss ich auch akut.
Ich habe schon mehrfach erbrochen.
Es kommt immer wieder so ein Würgereiz.
Ein Brächeriz.
Manchmal kommt etwas heraus, aber oft auch nicht.
Was meinst du, Würgereiz?
Würgereiz, es kommt mir hoch.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss erbrechen, aber es kommt nichts.
Aber ich habe schon heute trotzdem mehrfach erbrochen.
Wie sah Ihr Erbrechen aus?
Ich habe hier nicht viel gegessen. Ich kann ja nichts essen.
Es kommt gleich wieder raus.
Ich habe auch Durchfall.
Es ist uns Bauchschmerzen.
Bauchschmerzen und Durchfall.
Habt ihr heute im Brächen Blut gesehen?
Blut? Nein, ich habe sie nicht verstanden.
Es ist eher ein galliges Erbrechen.
Welche Farbe?
Galliges Erbrechen. Es ist gelb, grün und sehr bitter.
Wo genau haben Sie Bauchschmerzen?
Überall.
Aber mehr auf der rechten Seite und im Magenbereich.
Rechten Seite und Magenbereich.
Sie meinen Intermittell und Oberbauch?
Ja, wenn Sie das bezeichnen wollen.
Aber es ist der ganze Bauch.
Okay, in ganzem Bauch.
Sie haben auch Durchfall?
Seit wann haben Sie Durchfall?
Seit heute Nacht und heute Morgen.
Durchfall ist neu.
Und das Erbrechen auch.
Es ist auch seit heute Morgen akut.
Okay, aber seit ein paar Monaten.
Ja, das kommt immer wieder.
Immer die gleichen Symptome.
Es wird dann für ein paar Tage oder für einige Wochen gut.
Dann kommt es wieder, ganz plötzlich.
Schmerzen, sehr stark.
Und das ist seit heute Morgen akut.
Ich hatte letzte Woche überhaupt nichts.
Aber jetzt seit heute Morgen plötzlich wieder Schmerzen, Erbrechen.
Und ja.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihr Durchfall beschreiben?
Es ist wässrig und sehr hell.
Sie haben auch kein Blut bemerkt, richtig?
Nein, ich habe kein Blut gesehen.
Sehr gut.
Könnten Sie bitte auch Ihre Bauchschmerzen beschreiben?
Stechen, zurückhand, wie können Sie es beschreiben?
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass es gurgelt überall.
Manchmal ist es krampfartig.
Manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, es ist sehr stark gebläht.
Ja, sehr stark gebläht.
Was meinst du, geht?
Viel Luft im Bauch.
Ah, okay.
Volle Gefühle oder Beleihungen.
Ja.
Ja, haben Sie einen Ausschuss bemerkt, Frau Lawrence?
Nein.
Ich weiß es nicht, das kommt ganz plötzlich.
Oder gibt es etwas, das Sie verschmerzen, veröffentlichen oder verliehen?
Also ich habe sehr stark geachtet beim Essen, ob es irgendetwas gibt,
was die Schmerzen auslöst, aber ich habe nichts gefunden.
Okay, das ist nicht abhängig. Das ist unabhängig vom Essen, richtig?
Ja, ja.
Wir haben keine Gründe gefunden.
Nein, bisher nicht. Deswegen komme ich ja immer wieder zu Ihnen oder ins Krankenhaus.
Gibt es weitere Veränderungen in Ihrem Körper, z.B. Hautfarbeveränderung,
Augenfarbeveränderung oder haben Sie noch weitere Schmerzen?
Veränderungen habe ich nur gemerkt, dass mein Urin sehr dunkel ist.
Urin dunkel.
Ja.
Und auch, ja, Ihr Stuhl ist auch sehr heil.
Und haben Sie auch, ob Ihr Bauch, rechtsseitig Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, natürlich.
Ja, Sie haben ja, ich habe es verstanden. Ihre Bauchschmerzen in ganzem Bauch.
Auch, ja.
Aber gibt es aber keine bestimmte Ort.
Nur in der Mitte, ob er Bauch magen bereich und rechtsseitig unter.
Ja, verstanden, okay.
Aber meist films auf der rechten Seite.
Und Urin dunkel, das ist auch neu oder seit vor?
Ja, alles seit heute Morgen.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Schmerzen beim Wasser lassen?
Nein.
Ist besonders wieder nennender, okay.
Nein, nein, ich kenne das mit den Harnwechselinfektien.
Das habe ich immer wieder, aber jetzt nicht.
Nein.
Es ist nur, dass der Urin sehr dunkel ist.
Sehr dunkel, okay.
Ja, wie ernähren Sie sich gibt es bestimmte, haben Sie bestimmte Lebensgewohnheiten?
Oh, das ist im Prinzip so ziemlich alles.
Also Gemüse, Obst, Fleisch.
Okay, Sie können essen, alles gibt es, keine bestimmte Lebensmittel oder Esgewohnheiten.
Was meinen Sie mit Esgewohnheiten?
Ja, Sie können alles essen und gibt es...
Also ich vertrage bisher alles ganz gut.
Nein, okay, ich habe ein falscher Standort.
Frau Lörrans, sind Sie bei diesem Zeitraum wegen Ihrer Beschwerden bei Ihrem Hausarzt oder Ihrer Hausarztin gewesen?
Ja, ich bin sehr oft beim Hausarzt und war auch sehr oft im Krankenhaus wegen diesen Beschwerden.
Wie schon gesagt, das kommt immer wieder seit Monaten, aber man hat bisher nie etwas gefunden.
Okay, verstehe, haben Sie Fieber?
Heute Morgen hatte ich 37,8.
37,8, okay.
Und hatten Sie steilfrost nachschweiß oder kaltsche weiss?
Nein, nein.
Keine.
Klagen Sie über Herzrasen, Herzklopfen oder Frustenatmung?
Nein, ich fühle mich sehr schwach und sehr kraftlos.
Und nach dem Erbrochen oder nach dem Erbrechen?
Ja, im Allgemeinen, seit heute Morgen.
Ist Ihnen das schwierig?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Als im Moment gar nicht, aber ansonsten, wenn die Beschwerden nicht da sind, gar nicht ganz normalerweise hatten Sie kein Problem, okay?
Nein, nein.
Ja, Frau Lawrence, haben Sie in dieser Zeit ab oder zu genommen?
Nein.
Sie sehen, ich bin etwas übergewichtig, habe etwas mehr Kilos, aber das war schon immer so.
Ein bisschen, ja, ein bisschen, aber okay, aber gibt es keine Veränderung, ich verstehe.
Nein.
Und bei diesem Zeitraum hatten Sie Probleme beim Schlafen?
Bisher ansonsten alles gut.
Okay, ich verstehe so, Ihre Beschwerden, ja Sie hatten früher leichte Beschwerden und beim Schlafen hatten Sie keine Probleme.
Nein, nein.
Frau Lawrence, leiten Sie an chronische Erkrankungen?
Bisher noch nicht, nein.
Sie sind sehr jung, wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Nein, bisher habe ich keine Operation gehabt.
Oder sind Sie bisher in Krankenhaus geliebt?
Nein.
Okay, und Sie benutzen? Nein.
Nehmen Sie irgendwelche Medikamente, regeln Sie sie oder bei Bedarf ein?
Nein, nein.
Keine Medikamente?
Nein.
Auch jetzt, ich würde gerne etwas gegen die Schmerzen nehmen wollen, aber sobald ich etwas schlucke, kommt alles wieder raus.
Okay, ja, okay, Entschuldigung, ich habe vergessen, danke.
Sie hatten Bauchschmerzen.
Ja.
Sie haben momentan Bauchschmerzen?
Ja, sehr stark.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Schmerzen bewerben auf einer Schmerzgrafon 1 bis 10?
1 bedeutet sehr leicht und 10 bedeutet sehr stark.
Also manchmal würde ich sagen schon bei 6-7.
6-7.
Ja.
Können Sie bis zum Ende dieses Gesprächs aushalten oder brauchen Sie momentan ein Medikament?
Ja, also ein bisschen geht noch, aber es wäre schön, wenn ich bald etwas gegen die Schmerzen bekommen könnte.
Okay, okay, ich kann jetzt dieses Gespräch unterbrechen und ich kann Ihre Vitatparameter messen.
Und ich würde Blut abnehmen, im Labor bestimmen lassen.
Und ein paar Medikamente verabreichen.
Oh ja, das wäre sehr schön.
Okay, wenn Sie sich besser fühlen, können wir weiter machen.
Ja, bitte.
Ja, Frau Lawrence, haben Sie allergen oder Sie haben gesagt, Sie haben keine Unverzelligkeiten?
Nein.
Haben Sie allergen?
Rauchen Sie?
Nein.
Und ich verstehe so, Sie haben bisher nicht geraucht?
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
Nein, ich trinke kein Alkohol.
Sehr gut.
Ich habe eine rote Frage.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Nein, ich habe keine Drogen bisher.
Träuben Sie Sport?
Nein, leider nicht.
Würde ich gerne, aber mache ich nicht.
Ja, Frau Lawrence, sind Ihnen Ihre Familie chronisch oder relevante Erkrankungen bekannt?
Meine Tante hatte auch ähnliche Beschwerden.
Und die hat vor einem halben Jahr eine neue Diagnose bekommen, aber ich kann nicht sagen,
sie hat irgendetwas im Darm.
Okay, sie hatte ähnliche Beschwerden und in ihrem Darm wurde eine Diagnose festgestellt.
Aber Sie wissen nicht.
Und sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Meine Eltern sind gesund.
Okay, nur Tante.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ja, ich habe noch einen Bruder.
Einer Bruder ist gesund?
Ja, der hat bisher nichts.
Frau Lawrence, sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, mein Haushalt hat das alles überprüft und das war letztes Jahr alles in Ordnung.
Sind Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland gewiesen?
Nein.
Keine Reise, okay.
Was machen Sie beruflich, Frau Lawrence?
Ich bin Schülerin.
Schülerin?
Ja.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Nein.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Mit wem leben Sie?
Ich wohne noch bei meinen Eltern.
Eltern, okay.
Und bei diesem Zeitraum gibt es niemanden, der ähnliche Beschwerde hat, außer ihre Tante.
Genau, es gibt uns niemanden.
Frau Lawrence, haben Sie Rücken oder Flanken schmerzen?
Das ist auch nicht, ich glaube.
Nein, nein.
Haben Sie noch weitere Beschwerden?
Also nur Bauchschmerzen, ja.
Ja, alle Beschwerden sind so.
Haben Sie Zotberinnen oder Aufstößen?
Ja, natürlich.
Während Sie erbrechen?
Ja, aber es kommt viel Luft, ja, das stimmt.
Aber ansonsten normalerweise nicht, nur jetzt.
Haben Sie Verschrubprobleme?
Verschrubprobleme?
Verschrubprobleme, nein.
Okay, wir sind am Ende dieses Gesprächs, Frau Lawrence.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich möchte gerne wissen, was das ist.
Ich mache mir so langsam Sorgen und bekomme Angst.
Ja, ich verstehe Sie, Frau Lawrence, ja, ich habe eine Vermutung,
aber das ist sehr für etwas zu sagen.
Zunächst würde ich gerne Sie körperlich untersuchen
und danach eine Sonografie durchführen.
Sobald ich eine Ergebnisse erhalten habe,
werde ich Sie sofort informieren, was Sie haben.
Wunderbar, vielen Dank.
Legen Sie sich bitte auf die selbe Gestur-Untersuchung.
Ja, bitte.
Ich glaube, jetzt brauche ich etwas gegen meine Schmerzen, ja.
Und die Übelkeit ist ganz schlimm.
Ja, ich hatte einen Benutzer-Zugang gelegt
und ein paar Medikamente, wenn das reicht.
Aber ich werde weiter machen.
Es ist nur noch ganz wenig besser geworden, noch nicht ganz weg.
Okay.
Dankeschön.
Ich danke Ihnen.
Hat jemand noch Fragen?
Unsere Präsentin.
Ja, meine Frage.
Ja, bitte.
Entschuldigung. Können Sie mir sagen,
wann Ihre letzte Messeration war?
Da habe ich bisher keine Probleme.
Das ist immer regelmäßig. Das war jetzt vor zwei Wochen.
Darf ich?
Bitte, andere Fragen natürlich.
Frau Lawrence, haben Sie etwas als Ausloser in letzter Seite bemerkt?
Nein, lange nicht.
Wie ist die Farbe?
Ich habe keine Farbe, ich habe keine Stuhl.
Normalerweise, wenn ich keinen Durchfall habe,
völlig in Ordnung, ganz normal, braun.
Aber jetzt sehr hell und dünnflüssig.
Sehr hell und... ja.
Haben Sie Blut im Stuhl bemerkt?
Nein, das hatte ich auch schon gesagt. Nein, ich habe keinen Blut im Stuhl gesehen.
Danke.
Nein, keine OP.
Ich habe keine Fragen.
Ansonsten gebe ich vielleicht ein paar Ergebnisse von den Untersuchungen,
damit der Arzt die Übergabe machen kann an den Oberarzt.
Oder sind noch Fragen? Keine Stimme, keine Fragen, oder doch?
Wie viel mal hatten Sie für diese Bestwerten,
die Bestwerten, und wie lange gedauert ist?
Ja, seit einem halben Jahr.
Und dann geht es manchmal bis zu einer Woche.
Und dann ist es wieder weg.
Und dann, pro Monat, hätten Sie die Bestwerten...
Da habe ich das vielleicht fünf, sechs Mal schon gehabt.
Lieber, ich habe gesagt, ich habe...
Was habe ich gesagt? 37,8.
37,8.
Genau. Also, wir haben Ultraschall gemacht.
Im Ultraschall hat man eine ausgeprägte Blähung gesehen,
also viel Luft im Darm.
Keine freie Flüssigkeit in der Bauchhöhle.
Gallenblase, unauffällig.
Sehr schlanke Gallenblasenwand.
Keine Gallenblasesteine.
Der Gallengang, völlig normal.
DHC, Niere, beidseits unauffällig.
Kein Aufstau, keine Konkremente.
Leber, normale Größe.
In der Medioklavikularlinie, 11 cm.
Keine Auffälligkeiten, Paranthym der Leber, völlig unauffällig.
Kein Aufstau der Leberwähnen.
Mehls, normal groß, normales Paranthym.
Pankreas, sehr schlecht darzustellen wegen vieler Luft.
Aorta, weniger kawar-inferior, normal.
Handblase, wenig gefüllt.
Ansonsten, keine Auffälligkeiten.
Im Blabor, ein CRP von 9.
Das kleine Blutbild ist unauffällig.
Keine erhöhten Leukozytten.
Trombozytten normal.
Leberwerte, nur die Gamma-GT war normal.
Die GOT und GPT waren nur ganz leicht erhöht bei 50, glaube ich.
AP, Bilorubin, alkanische Phosphatase, Bilorubin, LDH, normwertig.
Normbereich.
Eisenwerte waren normal, Schilddrüse, TSA bei 5.
Also nur ganz minimal erhöht, aber sonst auch normal.
Was haben wir noch angeschaut?
Hansäure normal, Rokalcytolin negativ.
Ich glaube, das waren so die wichtigsten Werte.
Wir haben ihr als Schmerzmedikament intravenös, Novalgieneingramm,
plus MCP, Metaclopromit gegeben.
Danach ging es ihr relativ schnell besser.
Übelkeit wurde besser und die Schmerzen haben nachgelassen.
Das sind die Ergebnisse.
Aber es gibt momentan keine festgestellte Diagnose.
Das ist Ihre Aufgabe jetzt, Herr Doktor.
Ameliaselipase waren auch unauffällig.
Das haben wir auch gemacht, wichtig.
Ich hatte über geilem Wege etwas gedacht.
Das besprechen wir gleich.
Nach der Übergabe an den Urwarzen können wir unsere Verdacht mehr
und die Differenzialdiagnose diskutieren.
Aber Sie sind jetzt eine Art.
Sie müssen jetzt die Diagnose finden.
Wenn es keine Fragen gibt, kann ich mit dem Astrazgespräch anfangen.
Bitte schön.
Hallo, guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag, Herr Doktor Kemal.
Grüß Gott, wie geht es Ihnen?
Vielen Dank, ich hoffe, es geht Ihnen auch gut.
Wenn ich Sie sehe, bitte schön.
Danke, Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patiente aufgenommen.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne vorstellen, hätten Sie kurz seid.
Aber natürlich, bitte schön.
Danke, Herr Oberarzt.
Die 22-jährige Patiente, nämlich Frau Sarah Lawrence,
ist 1,65 m, 73 kg schwer.
Frau Lawrence stand sich heute bei uns wegen starken,
wegen bestehenden, prokredienten,
und verbrechen.
Die Patiente berichtet, dass sie seit ein paar Monaten
diese Beschwerde hatte.
Aber heute sind ihre Schmerzen zerstackt geworden
und nicht heute, seit gestern.
Seit heute Morgen.
Seit heute Morgen sind ihre Beschwerden zerstackt geworden
und sie hat ein paar Mal erbrochen.
Aber ihr Erbitechen sah esreste und kein Blut aus.
Ihr Erbitechen war grün und gelblich.
Frau Lawrence gab an, dass sie auch, wie gesagt,
Bauchschmerzen hat, ins besondere Unterbauch,
in der Mitte des Epigastikbereichs,
aber sie fühlte ihre Schmerzen in ganzem Bauch.
Und ihre Bauchschmerzen ist auch krampfartig.
Es gibt keine Ausschluhrsa, laut der Patientin
und bei diesem Zeitraum klagte sie auch Astheni,
Fatik und sie klagte auch über
Metorismus und Ruktus.
Ich habe vergesst, eine Entschuldigung.
Ihre Schmerzintensität liegt bei 6 bis 7 von 10 auf der Schmerzkala.
Auf den Grund habe ich das Analysegespräch unterbrochen.
Ich habe einen Venetianzugang gelegt
und habe eine symptomatische Behandlung begonnen.
Natürlich am Anfang Vitalparameter.
Ihre Vitalparameter gemessen, Herr Oberarzt.
Die Venetianatese ist unauffällig,
bis auf Beschwerde bedickte in Appetanz.
Sie hat keine Fieber,
aber ihr körperliche Temperatur ist,
war heute 37,8.
Vorher Kranken, Operationen und Medikamente-Geschichte wurden verneint.
Sie hat keine Allergie, keine Unvertiligkeiten,
Nikotenkonsum, Alkoholkonsum, Drogenkonsum, alle wurden verneint.
An ihrer Familienanamnese sind ihre Eltern auch gesund.
Sie hat auch eine gesunde Bruder.
Aber sie berichtete, dass ihre Tante ähnliche Beschwerde hatte.
Vor ein paar Monaten wurde eine Diagnose festgestellt,
aber sie wusste nicht, was es ist.
Sie ist vollständig geimpft.
Die Reiseanamnese ist unauffällig.
Die Frau ist auch unauffällig.
Sie ist Schülerin, sie ist leidig und lebt mit ihrer Familie.
Sie treibt keinen Sport.
Herr Oberarzt, die Anamnese-Angaben deuten am 1.
Auf einer Kulitis oder Kulistitis hin,
garen wegen Stenoise, denke ich eigentlich.
Differenzial Diagnostisch kommen Ulcus ventriculi
oder Finac pancreatitis in Betracht.
Bei der Diagnose, werde ich die Patienten körperlich untersuchen.
Bei dieser Untersuchung werde ich darauf achten,
ob Durukschmerzen, Losslossschmerzen,
Abwehrspannung, Hautfarbeveränderung,
insbesondere Icterus vorhanden sind.
Nach der körperlichen Untersuchung werde ich die Blut abnehmen.
Im Labor 5-Timen zu lassen.
Dabei würde ich ein großes Blutbild, ein Sundungsparameter,
Leberwerte, Nierenwerte,
Urin-Test, Stuhl-Test,
Lipaz, Amylas, Pankras, Enzyme,
Bestimen Nase,
nach der Laboruntersuchung würde ich eine Ablomensonographie
und komponente Tomografie durchführen.
Sollte sich die Diagnose bestätigen,
werde ich die Patienten stationär aufnehmen.
Oder kann ich auch ambulant behandeln,
aber das ist abhängig von den Ergebnissen.
Ich werde, ich habe es gemacht, wenn wir uns in der Zukunft legen,
ich werde symptomatische Behandlungen beginnen
mit Analgetikum, Spasmulitikum und Anteemitikum.
Wenn es ein Problem mit der Galenamwege,
ich meine Stenose,
wenn es gibt, können wir auch ERCP durchführen.
Es gibt keine, in ihrem Leben kann ich nichts sehen,
keine Vorerkrankungen, keine Noxen,
ich kann vielleicht Sport empfehlen.
An welche, also Sie haben ja schon eine Fidatsdiagnose geschildert,
Akkulizistitis,
oder Litiasis,
oder Litiasis, genau.
Eigentlich gibt es ja schon.
Ihre Differenzialdiagnose.
Ja, Ulcus ventruguli,
oder Pancreatitis,
ja, die Patienten berichten,
dass sie dunkel üren hat,
dunkel üren und stul,
heller stul hat, hat.
Sie haben keine Ärzte,
wenn sie auch diese Beschwerde hatte,
ich dachte eigentlich,
keine Anwege, Stenose.
Ja, aber welche Erkrankungen,
an welche Erkrankungen muss man trotzdem denken,
das heißt, wenn sie jetzt immer wieder Durchfälle hat,
immer wieder Erbrechen hat.
Eigentlich Unvertätigkeit,
ich kann nicht denken, seit ein paar Monaten hat sie diese Beschwerden,
oder ja,
Sie haben ja gesagt, die Tante hat ja auch eine Diagnose vom Darum gehabt.
Ja.
Ernst so, woran müssen Sie noch denken,
was kann bei ihr auch sein?
Ja, das ist interessant und komisch.
Rezidivierende Durchfälle, Bauchkrämpfe,
woran denken Sie,
wie kann man das mit Leitmotiv oder Leitzytom?
Normalerweise denke ich an nur
Unvertätigkeiten.
Okay, kann jemand helfen,
was für Beschwerden im Darum kann zurück?
Ja, ob es Corona oder ein Freund hat es geschrieben.
Chronisch-entzündliche Darumerkrankungen.
Okay, okay.
Das ist ein junger Bau, keine Vorerkrankungen.
Das heißt, man muss einmal aus Corona denken,
an Qualitis Ulcerosa muss man natürlich denken.
Ja, ja, ja.
Was Sie völlig vergessen haben, ist Reizdamsyndrom.
Kann natürlich auch sein, die Kollegen haben das aufgeschrieben.
Junge Frau, woran müssen Sie noch denken,
was kann doch Unterbauch oder allgemeinen Bauchschmerzen machen?
Können Sie wiederholen bitte? Ich habe ihn nicht.
Woran muss man noch denken,
was kann die Frau noch haben? Eine junge Frau?
An welchen Erkrankungen muss man natürlich auch denken,
was Bauchschmerzen auslösen kann?
Darf ich es sagen?
So, wer ist jetzt dran?
Da, ja.
Irgendjemand hat, ah, wer will eine Frage stellen?
Ja, Schwangerschaft.
Schwangerschaft, natürlich. Woran denkt man?
Einleiter Schwangerschaft. Aber seid.
Normale Schwangerschaft.
Ja, wenn es eine Verbindung gibt mit der Tante.
Ja.
Ob das Urs oder nicht, das müsste man herausfinden.
Ja, verstehe, verstehe.
Es geht um die Differenzialdiagnosen,
an welche Erkrankungen man natürlich mitdenken muss
und dann muss man die einzeln ausschließen.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Weil über die Übelkeit ist sehr viel.
Genau.
Aber der letzte Regalblutung war vor zwei Wochen.
Das ist richtig.
Trotzdem, wir müssen mal die Gynäkologen fragen.
Die können Geschichten erzählen.
Oder die Frau denkt,
dass sie Regelblutungen hat,
oder die Armbutungen.
Das ist möglich.
Wir müssen das ausschließen.
Ich möchte nur sagen, bei Schwangerschaften
können wir akute Überlehrung sehen.
Aber meistens beginnt es langsam
und danach stärker Überlehrung.
Herr Doktor, Sie haben recht.
Natürlich.
Es geht darum,
wenn akute jemand kommt, an welche Erkrankungen denken Sie?
Verstehe.
Schließen Sie diese Überlegungen auch aus?
Sie sagen Schwangerschaft da eher nicht, weil diese Gründe.
Das ist schon klar.
Aber Sie müssen zumindest an diese Möglichkeit denken.
Wenn man nach der Differenzialdiagnosen
eine junge Frau mit Unterbauchschmerzen,
dann müssen Sie immer an etwas Gynäkologisches denken.
Das kann Schwangerschaft,
eine Eileiterentzündung,
eine Eierstockentzündung, eine Züste am Eierstock,
eine Blutung, eine Eileiter Schwangerschaft,
eine Bauchhöhlen Schwangerschaft.
Sie müssen an eine Endometriose denken.
Das ist jetzt zum Beispiel, das ist alles Gynäkologisch.
Verstehen Sie?
Natürlich.
Das mache ich sehr breit.
Sie müssen an einem, was wir überhaupt gar nicht besprochen haben,
einem Darmbruch, an einer Perforation denken.
Vielleicht hat sie eine kleine Perforation,
das immer wieder zu Entzündungen führt.
Jetzt wenn wir noch mal wieder auf den Darmen kommen.
Vorhin kam noch mal Diverticulitis.
Das haben Sie gar nicht gesagt.
Oder eine kronische Appendicitis.
Vielleicht hat sie eine eitrige,
immer wiederkehrende Entzündung
an der Appendix,
was immer wieder beschwert macht.
Da hat sie Bauchschmerzen, Fieber, Magenschmerzen.
Das Hauptsymptom bei einer Appendicitis
fängt meistens mit Magenschmerzen an.
Bei gerade bei jungen Menschen.
Deswegen, wenn ihr mal Oberbauchschmerzen habt,
muss man auch wieder an eine Appendicitis denken.
Ich war selbst, ich glaube,
Entschuldigung?
Jetzt hat es mir in der Nase gejuckt.
Als Student, ich glaube,
fünfmal wegen Magenschmerzen
im Krankenhaus,
an einer fast perforierten Appendicitis operiert wurde.
Deswegen vergesse ich Appendicitis nicht.
Auch daran muss man denken.
Das sind also die Differenzialdiagnose,
die man erwähnen sollte.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit, ob und vielleicht,
oder ganz selten, oder gar nicht klar,
das muss man dann immer anhand der Ergebnisse
der Untersuchungen mit Ultraschall,
mit Laboregipenis, mit CT oder MRT,
je nachdem, welche Diagnostik man macht,
muss man dann natürlich den Verdacht bestätigen
oder ausschließen.
Aber man muss halt daran denken.
Das ist einfach wichtig.
Und eventuell müssen Sie natürlich ein Konzil beantragen.
Dass man sagt, ich hole in den Chirurgen,
ich schick sie noch mal zum Gynecologen.
Was haben Sie bei dieser Untersuchung?
Labores gibt nichts klares her.
Welche Untersuchungen würde Sie als nächstes empfehlen?
Was ist die große Wahrscheinlichkeit,
was Sie sein könnten?
Was können wir empfehlen?
Und weitere Untersuchungen.
Labore haben Sie gemacht?
Ja, Konoskopie.
Eine Konoskopie,
eine chronische Damenentsunung.
Und wir werden dann auch Biopsy durchführen.
Genau, man kann eine Biopsy entnehmen
und kann schauen, ob da eine chronische Entzündung ist.
Und die Tante hatte die Diagnose,
weil die Tante war eine akute, was war das?
Eine Kulitisterminalis.
Also das war eine,
eine Kulitisulcerosa.
Die bekommt jetzt eine Therapie dagegen.
Und die hatte ähnliche Symptome.
Und wie alt war Ihre Tante?
Ich glaube 42.
42, okay. Sie ist auch jung.
Ja, verstehe.
Interessante, interessante.
Ja, das war die Tante.
Interessanter Fall.
Ja, Doktor, nicht falsch verstehen.
Ich möchte Sie nicht verärgern,
sondern ich möchte einfach nur die Prüfungssituation simulieren
und auch den Punkt da auf Lenken.
Dass man natürlich auch, wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit gering ist,
an diese Diagnosen, an die differenzialen Diagnosen
natürlich denkt.
Klar, Sie denken daran und schließen das gleich aus.
Das habe ich gemerkt. Also das sind Sie schon sehr gut.
Aber in der Prüfung muss man das natürlich auch zu sparen.
Ja, verstehe. Vielen Dank.
Okay, hat jemand noch andere Ideen?
Ich habe jetzt die ganzen Chats gar nicht gelesen.
Stuhlprobe, Ultraschalkontrast, gastroenteritis.
Klar, auch etwas ganz Einfaches muss man denken.
Vielleicht ist es einfach nur eine virale gastroenteritis.
Das kann natürlich auch sein.
Ja, das ist eine gute Idee.
Illus, eventuell, aber eher weniger wahrscheinlich.
Meccyldiveticulitis pylorostinose.
Genau, das sind Porphyrye, gute Idee.
Im Urin war leider überhaupt kein Bilorubin.
Das habe ich vergessen zu sagen, der Urin ist konzentriert.
Ich hätte gedacht, im Urin wäre viel Bilorubin,
aber da war nichts.
Und an einer Hepatitis, glaube ich,
muss man auch mal denken, oder?
Das wollte ich auch jetzt sagen.
Da muss man eben Labor nochmal schauen, ob da
die Hepatitis-Titer oder Antikörper erhöht sind oder nicht.
Er hat finde,
Übelkeit war meine Diagnose
akute gastroenteritis.
Sie hat sehr schnell reagiert auf Novalgien
und MCP, war relativ schnell
mit den Schmerzen deutlich besser,
nachdem die Laborwerte auch minimal verändert waren.
Kaum CRP, Leberwerte kaum verändert,
Blutbedniere, die Pankrass-Enzyme, alles unauffällig.
Ich denke, dass es eventuell in Richtung
gruntsche Darmenzündung geht.
Ich wollte jetzt einfach in den nächsten Tagen
wieder eine Laborkontrolle machen,
um zu schauen, wie verändern sich die Werte,
bekommt sie noch CRP oder doch noch ein Anstieg der
Transaminasen, also der Leberwerte.
Und auf jeden Fall will ich sie noch zur
Abklärung in die Gastroenterologischik
zur Magenspiegelung und Darmspiegelung.
Gynäkologisch glaube ich nicht, dass sie da
irgendwas hat.
Da stimme ich dem Kollegen zu.
Aber wenn es nicht besser wird mit den Schmerzen,
muss man sie auch mal bei den Gynäkologen
vorstellen.
Das wäre so für mich der nächste Schritt gewesen.
Weil Sie Duckel, Irin und Heller-Schul
gesagt haben, dann haben wir gedacht,
es könnte Kolesistitis.
Das war auch ein erster Gedanke.
Die hatte eine Ganenblasenstein,
das ist irgendwo vielleicht im gernen Gang.
Aber im Unterhör war alles okay.
War sonografisch alles okay.
Und auch im Labor, zumindest hätte man
im Labor erwartet, hohe Gamma-GT, hohe Entzündungszeichen,
Leberwerte, Bilorobin, alles hoch, aber war nix.